rushing to catch the last trains before
the Lunar New Year many of these
passengers of the Beijing west railway
station are thinking of the coronavirus
don't think this virus has been properly
controlled I just came back to China I
read a lot of news Internet I'm not very
satisfied with how the government
prevented and controlled the disease I'm
very afraid of getting infected I am
really afraid of those people who lived
in left 400 but I do hope the situation
in Wuhan can be improved so much and
those inside the city of Wuhan are
becoming more frustrated because medical
supplies are running short and hospitals
are short-staffed many festivals for the
Lunar New Year holiday have been
cancelled across China and not just in
the central Hubei Province the epicenter
of the virus the government has closed
the Forbidden City here in Beijing over
health concerns related to the corona
virus something they didn't do some 17
years ago during the SARS crisis the
Chinese government was criticized for
the way it handled the SARS virus back
in 2003 mainly for its lack of
transparency the World Health
Organization has decided not to declare
the current outbreak a global health
emergency
but there's growing concern over the
coming week when the millions of people
who have travelled for the holiday
returned again raising the risk the
virus may be spread further by people
who are contaminated but have yet to
show symptoms
Scott Hodler al-jazeera Beijing